Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in our
listing of the invalidators of yesterday
we mentioned a general invalidator of
anything that comes out of the two
private parts.
Meaning the front private parts, the
back private part. Anything
that comes out of these two ways is
considered to be an invalidator of
the second is
deep sleep. Not just sleep.
Notice the wording that the author uses.
Deep sleep.
Now the question that's obvious when
hearing such a a thing and that is how
do we quantify
deep sleep? what distinguishes what
is the boundary the distinguishing
contrasting line between deep sleep and
light sleep? And why is it that only
deep sleep
breaks a person's wool whereas light
sleep does not? Both of them are sleep.
These are two very important questions.
Number one,
sleep itself does not break a person's
woo.
Sleep itself
does not break a person's woo.
Sleep
is considered an invalidator of wool
because
that which does break a person's wudul
could have occurred while a person is
sleeping and they would be none the
wiser. The reason why
sleep is considered an invalidator of
wudoo is not because sleep in itself
invalidates wudoo
but because a person
is when they wake up from deep sleep
they cannot with any certainty say that
they did not break their wool.
This is the reason deep sleep breaks a
person's wudoo is considered to be an
invalidator of wudoo.
So when a person stands to make wudoo
and they make their wudoo they can say
with certainty that they have wudoo
correct and they can say with certainty
that they did not break their woo.
Right? But when a person has something
deep sleep occur,
now that which was certain is no longer
certain. You can no longer claim with
certainty that you still have woo.
If we understand this about sleep,
then all of the evidences that have to
do with sleep and sleeping and woo and
they all fall into place. So for
instance,
for instance, the prophet sallall.aii
was
narrated on many occasions
to have
to have woken up from sleep and made
salah. Did not make wool.
he didn't make wudoo again
and other instances he would wake up
from sleep and not and and make wudoo
before making salah.
So the question is
why is he making salah after waking up
from sleep and we know it's deep sleep
sleep for hours
but he will make wake up make salah not
make
why is this happening well specifically
for the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu
Allah.
for
[Silence]
the
description.
of the prophets and messengers is that
their eyes sleep but their hearts do not
sleep. Why? Because the heart is the
recipient of revelation from Allah. Gibl
he descends from the heavens bearing the
revelation of Allah and he addresses the
heart. The heart is to be in constant
in constant
in in constant
wait
lying in constant wait for the
revelations of Allah to arrive. The
revelation is not going to wait from
Allah till he wakes up. He's sleeping
now. Wait until he wakes up to have the
revelation. Thank you. I'm all thumbs
this morning to have the revelation.
Revelation comes when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala deems it necessary. So the heart,
their hearts, the prophets and
messengers are always awake, waiting for
Allah's revelation. Their bodies sleep,
their hearts are constantly awake. Okay.
So for this reason, if the heart is what
is awake, the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam has a very unique
a very unique quality and that is
that no matter how deep his sleep is he
is going to know if he breaks his woo or
not. So in narrations where he's
narrated to wake up and make wudoo that
means while he was asleep he broke his
woo.
And in narrations that mention that he
woke up and did not make wudoo and made
salah. This means that
he did not break his wudoo during his
sleep. And he knows this. We do not have
this feature. When we fall asleep in a
deep sleep, we are unaware of what our
body is doing.
Therefore, when a person goes to sleep,
he is certain of his wudoo.
But then when he wakes up from his deep
sleep, he is no longer certain of his
wudoo. And you may not approach salah
with doubt.
You must be certain of your woodoo. in
order to approach salah. And so for this
reason we see a difference of opinion
amongst the scholars. Some of them say
deep sleep is what breaks wudoo. Light
sleep does not. Others say any kind of
sleep breaks woo. Others say no sleep
breaks woo. The correct opinion is that
deep sleep breaks woo.
Not because it sleep in itself breaks a
person's woo but because it is it is an
expected time for woo to be broken
[Silence]
and no for
feminine.
Listen to this narration from Ali.
The author even mentions it here. He
says
that the eye
the eye is the leash of the anus.
What does that mean? The eye
is the leash. You know, a leash you
would put on an animal to keep control
of it. The eye is the leash of the anus
which controls what the gases in the
body from coming out. So Ali says so
whoever sleeps
then he has to make woo.
So when a person sleeps deeply,
that sleep in and of itself does not
break a person's wudoo.
But that sleep
makes his wudoo dubious. Makes his wudoo
doubtful. He's unsure if he has woo or
not.
Therefore, deep sleep will make a
person's wudoo
be on shaky ground. It's uncertain now.
So a person must then
restore the certainty of his woo.
And how do we restore this certainty of
our woo? By making it right.
And so sleep in itself
does not break a person's wuboo.
But sleep
becomes what? It becomes a doubtful. It
adds a layer of doubt to a person's
wuboo. This is why a person is to sleep
is to make wuboo when he sleeps. But not
just any sleep, deep sleep.
And this takes us to the second point.
The first point was
why is it that deep sleep breaks a
person's woo but light sleep doesn't? We
answered that. The second question now
is how do we quantify
deep sleep and distinguish it from light
sleep? How do I say this is light sleep
and this is deep sleep? What is the
dividing line? What is the contrasting
line between the two? And that is what
we'll discuss tomorrow inshallah.